We felt the risk idea was so obvious that every all the major industries will pick it up and trample is underfoot
What was surprising?
[was] that it took the major companies a very long time?
To even think risk was worth
considering
and
And so we got at least a five-year
[Headstart] over them
So we got this process so and we thought well [that] works rather nicely. It's quite cheap
We can just make these and put them in our desktop products
We thought well actually this works efficiently
Well, it would be quite nice. If we found some other uses, and we did license it to VLsI technology in
1987 and
interestingly it found its way into a
Radius graphics accelerator for the Apple Machines apple - I think it was so apple
Started using arm through indirectly much earlier than they thought
But we never really [thought] we were
Competing with the big boys. We just thought we had a niche that we could
possibly slide through and
when
Apple [came] knocking on the door [that] which was actually after I left acorn I left acorn in august
92 come to Manchester
And it must have been a month or two after that apple came knocking and saying we have this Newton product we've been
Working with the AT&T hobbit, but actually we think the arm is better suited
but we're not that happy with the Arm being owned by [a]
competitor
How about we set this up as a joint venture and of course they were knocking on open door acorn had been?
trying for a couple of years to offload the overhead [of]
supporting arm development from his own product sales
and so the company was up and running in soif and [Baalbek] by [November], which is a
remarkable rate of Progress
even then the people that formed arm [and]
Robin Saxby was brought in to lead it, but the people that formed the core team with the people
Who I'd worked with at acorn, and they were all nervously laughing about you know saxbys
vision of World domination
I mean Robin was firmly the view that you had to think this was going to be a global standard
Because that was the only way you could succeed in processes you either take the world by storm or you disappear
but I think it was quite some time before even his own colleagues started to
Buy into this view one of the interesting observations of course is that
[although] we now think of Newton as a failure it is the Newton that made arm
Because then as now the Apple Brand
was about the biggest brand in the business and
On was supplying apple and therefore that opened all sorts of doors
they got licensees signing up almost queuing up just because of the apple name and
By the time it was beginning to become clear [that] Newton was not going to succeed
it didn't matter so much but for the first Few [years] of army was crucial in 95 they got the Nokia business and
Through Texas instruments, I think and you know since then they've never looked back, Nokia with the biggest name of the biggest
brand so Impose on
Nokia was by far the [biggest] brand in in mobile phone handsets in the [mid-90s] and getting that brand basically
And you will make now this is not to say that that the company hasn't had to work very diligently at
Maintaining and improving that position and mobile phones are not everything
They sell in fact I think only half
The the the 12 billion arm shipped in the last year went into mobile phones, so that means six billion went somewhere else
Thanks to squarespace [com] for sponsoring this episode of computer Val and if you go over [to] squarespace [comm] slash computer file
Slash computer file you can build a website with [they're] easy to use [and] [very] intuitive tools
They've got state-of-the-art
Technology which ensures stability and security and computer files might want to check out their developers platform at developers
Squarespace comm you can start building that website today without
Entering any credit card details and when you do make your first purchase if you use the offer code computer file
You'll get 10% off. So thanks once again to squarespace for sponsoring this computer of our video
The company that was running most parallel
To the risk thinking was actually in moss in Bristol with the transputer now if you look at the philosophy behind the transputer
Simplicity is [rit] very large
But their approach to simplicity was different from [Risc] the transmuter is not
Inspired or influenced by risk in the way that risk was arms [middle-name] when it was the acorn Risc machine